le surf a commencé en juillet 57
j'ai connu un américain qui a fait venir
une planche de californie parce que il
avait vu que les vagues ici devait s'y
prêter je me suis pas mal casser la
figure au début et puis ensuite ça a été
un petit peu mieux mais les jaf comme
vous voyez vous verrez si vous si vous
comprendrez après c'est vraiment cette
impression de dominer la vague et de
faire ce qu'on veut sur une planche qui
est extraordinaire
le surfing il fera fureur cet été sur
nos plages c'est au tableau noir qu'on
apprend les trois positions clés à plat
ventre sur la planche pour gagner le
large à poppy et enfin debout pour le
retour sous la poussée de la va vous
montrer parce que vous voyez vous parlez
par le chu
sans doute pensez vous à présent que le
surfing est un sport passionnant comme
l'ont prouvé pour la première fois en
france les champions de biarritz et on a
montré je crois encore aujourd'hui que
le possible peut exister
il n'y a pas de requins comme en
australie il ya des plages de sable
l'année suivante à 58 nous étions déjà
cinq ou six et en 59 une dizaine et
maintenant on peut dire que le nombre de
surfeurs double facilement tous les ans
peut ne rien faire tout temps présent
quelque chose à part qu'il ne sait rien
comme ça et qui depuis se refaire
[Musique]